do you think the Lakers make the
playoffs dan I have been wrestling with
this one for a while III think so but if
you ask me to put a you know a number of
confidence on that it's gonna be very
low I mean part of it is that the two
teams that the Lakers are chasing
absolutely loathe the Lakers the
Clippers and Kings you you know you
prefer to lead you know how much those
two franchises and their families have
just hate the Lakers it would like
nothing more than to eliminate them
specifically so that's gonna be quite a
climb I mean I think they start off with
these five row games they they gotta go
by three and two just to about fall so
far back that they're there they're
looking at too much to overcome but
didn't they preach patience at the
beginning of the season and then all of
a sudden that changed when they got it
felt like they were getting nervous and
then they decide that they're gonna go
all-in on Anthony Davis and now you're
sort of left with you know the
aftershocks here and it feels like it's
kind of a it's an unsteady locker room I
got LeBron who might not be in shape I
got Luke Walton on the hot seat there
and I got a bunch of young kids going
when do we get not if we get traded but
when we get traded well now yes to
answer your question they did preach
patience and I thought you know the
injury change the injuries of LeBron
changed it all I'm missing 18 games but
they were they were in fourth place in
the West and when LeBron went out yeah
and LeBrons never missed this kind of
time so we go back and look at those 18
games with 15 of them with LeBron and
lineup what are we looking at we're not
looking at them I was in 10th place now
so I think the panic came because they
sell out and I don't see the need for
the panic I'm not one of those people
who thinks that the supporting cast is
inadequate for everything if you can't
tell me that that if playing with if
Ingram and Kuzma hey let's take ball out
of the conversation for a second he's
hurt but if you put those guys in the
lineup with LeBron for 18 more games you
can't tune they're not better I look at
that lineup and I think you know what
they're probably close to as good if not
as good
as the Cleveland cast of characters at
LeBron one with last year okay they are
Kevin Love that's the one place where
you'd look at and say okay it's upgrade
Cleveland over this lineup yes they're
young yeah but they knew that going in I
saw I'm with you on that that you know
this going in and to me LeBron is the
one who I don't know seems like he was
stunned by this and he he plays against
these guys he knew what they were so I
took me there's a lot of I don't know
created drama as our dear friend Mark
Jackson was a fake hustle fake drama I
just I don't I don't really understand
why well I guess the injuries why the
injury the missing 18 games is why the
story you know flipped itself you saw
him at the all-star game all-star
weekend i I thought he looked and I was
trying to be polite politically correct
yesterday he he looked heavier he looked
like he was about 10 or 15 pounds he
just doesn't look like LeBron who
started the season or maybe even last
season did you notice I mean he built
more like Zion Williamson now yeah I
didn't notice that as much as he's tired
okay I don't mean tired from this he's
tired and he you know he talked about
remember the postgame chat after the the
most recent games I think his plate he
says I just got to get away from this
for a while it sounds like those
previous couple you know he would go
down the south beach and disappear for
he can't do any of that and so to me
that the I don't know what I noticed
when I'm looking at him is okay is he is
he
energized to the point where this is
something he can do you know I tell you
why I said this you know a week or so
ago I meant it
if I'm if I'm the all those young Lakers
and I had to go through what I had to go
through here all this trade stuff and
Anthony Davis and we're not good enough
and there are five packages that the New
Orleans pelicans could take and we're in
all of them I did a little bra to say
hey icon lead us
leave us we've seen you take nothing
teams not just to the playoffs but the
finals lead us you know we are I think
they are good enough but at every turn
it's it's you know how inadequate they
are I'm not saying that they can beat
gold and say they can't but you know I
look at the u.s. also has some flawed
situations in their Portland is is they
may have gotten better with some of
these acquisitions I don't know they're
Portland's good enough to win a couple
of rounds in the playoffs Denver is
telling me a fight team it's terrific as
half as they have I'm not sure they're
ready for that either I mean it the
Lakers are this group of Lakers as
constitute it ought to be better and I
think they I really think was a 16 and
10 when LeBron went out yeah I did that
you know him being out as long as he was
out that to me Dan is something that I
don't know I'm gonna see it didn't need
to happen cuz I'm not one who questioned
his injuries I just don't but that to me
is ways put them in this position
talking to Michael Wilbon pardon the
interruption co-host joining us Dan
Patrick show I'm also wondering about
this and I'm big into body language and
I noticed this at the all-star game and
the shooter rounds it felt like
everybody had a buddy LeBron didn't have
a buddy and I wonder he knows the clock
is ticking and he's got to get somebody
in at least one star in this offseason
if not to and who are those one or two
stars going to be now you sound like you
believe in the Kevin Durant theory Dan
that nobody wants to play with LeBron is
it you know it's interesting I don't
think it has to be any specific person
yeah one look I love Anthony Davis and
I'm predisposed to liking him anyway
being a Chicago guy as I am I love it
the Davis I'm not trade the whole team
for him I mean this is not like this is
not like trading for Kareem in 1970
whatever for whatever the Lakers traded
with the Box this isn't
I mean Anthony Davis is a he's a
wonderful player a whole team worth and
so I don't know I don't know who that
got gonna be I I do I do feel this way
though I know the narrative is you know
switched and who's gonna play with
LeBron and maybe people don't want to
play with him I believe that enough
people will want to play with LeBron um
it's gonna have to take place obviously
this summer they couldn't do it for the
trade deadline yeah and I think we
should have known that going it was
going to be really difficult to pull off
a mega trade at the deadline and I
realized that you're rich Paul was
trying to you know make that happen by
putting public pressure on our New
Orleans to do it but there's a lot of
free guys and they and even if they
don't Dan even if they're scared of
playing with LeBron even if there's some
nervousness about that
it's the Lakers that's the place you
know warm weather cities that's where
guys go California is where guys are
going to want to go what combination I
don't know but that's what magic Johnson
and LeBron have to get done as soon as
they're eliminated for this season
whenever that is would you rather have
Anthony Davis or klay Thompson on the
Lakers you know if you if you told me I
could just add klay Thompson and keep
some of the other parts I might do that
at klay Thompson and somebody else if
that's true
who does somebody else would be
necessarily but suppose if somebody else
was boogie cousins I mean you it doesn't
have to be direct
Kyrie or Anthony Davis I don't believe
that yeah okay those guys are great
they're all great they have three
championships between us so I if it was
klay Thompson and that allowed me still
klay Thompson right now then it sounds
like you and I agree on this I just
think he's I think he's maybe the most
underrated player in the league the last
three years those people started listing
all the butyl Golden's they place and
they start putting clay Thompson like
forth I'm like hold on I mean yeah I
realize you definitely put them behind
Durant and step but klay Thompson is a
hell of a player I'm like you if they
had him
and given that specific skill set I
might rather have him in combination
with somebody else if you could place
Zion Williamson as the Commissioner for
the for the good of the league where
would you place him
well I've everybody wants me to say New
York the league functions just fine with
the Knicks being a dog
the league is function just fine with
the Knicks being a dog for most of the
last 23 years so I'm not necessarily
gonna say New York I mean I got my own
bias you know I'd love to see him in
Chicago I'd love to see him you know go
to a place where there's been a little
more not not much more recent success
but some they've got in the Conference
Finals but but in terms of like the bad
teams the teams that we know we're going
to be in the lottery is just somebody is
there someplace in there's just
irresistible is there a small market
situation I don't I don't know I mean I
if he goes if you go to the Knicks then
I'm not gonna be upset because the
Knicks are so bad it's warranted his
right don't want to see him I don't want
to see him in Cleveland because
Cleveland's had wood LeBron Kyrie
Wiggins and the kid from Vegas but what
do you is there a domino effect that it
could happen let's say the Knicks win
the lottery right then all of a sudden
if you're Kyrie and/or Kevin Durant do
you then does that make get a little
more enticing out more a lot more a lot
more yeah I mean you know it's
interesting to be a Charlotte this past
weekend and just you know the previous
week I was in Southern California to
what the studio things I would also get
a chance go to a couple games and you
know the reason this whole thing popped
up during the Anthony Davis crazy talk
was that the players and coaches and
agents and people in the NBA Dan
believed a lot of them and and helped
fuel the fire about who's going to New
York yeah and all the the Kevin Durant
and Kyrie talked that stuff didn't cut
it wasn't just like media
generated that was it was it was
generated in the dissemination came to
us but but there are there people
talking openly about it which means
where'd they get it and you know what a
gossip league the NBA is a much more so
to me than the other leagues the NBA
thrives on that does it mean that
everything is true no it doesn't but it
does mean that this talk was generated
from people who have conversations who
are on the court in in locker rooms and
in proximity to those guys well I said
the last time you were on that KD was
not going to LA because he doesn't want
he he thinks he's the best player in the
game and he might be the best player in
the game he doesn't want to help LeBrons
legacy and that's why I said that I
think he's done with Golden State he
doesn't want to be the villain he ruined
basketball for a few years he can go to
New York maybe Kyrie is good and I go
back to when I went to the premiere of
uncle drew Kady came in and he sat right
behind us because he's best friends with
Kyrie Irving he's not even in the movie
and he went to the premiere I keep
people up I listen the thing that I've
heard Dan is just again from people who
share court space and time and you know
it could be you know opponents are
opponents anymore these guys don't hate
each other by and large just the
opposite the idea is that both of them
the Kyrie and Kevin I'm sure you talked
about this in previous shows that they
don't feel that the championships they
won are theirs belong to them primarily
and that's what that's what the
preoccupation with doing it somewhere
else is waiting somewhere else because
that would be their championship so I
you know there's a lot of time I don't
spend a lot of time insisting I know
what it's like looking at poll numbers
in August and trying to tell me you know
what's going to happen November 4th I
mean eyes it's you know that I don't
necessarily believe in that but I but
there's so much smoke there's so much I
know and and I
you you start thinking okay what is it
that these guys are thinking I know
other players are thinking about this so
so do you think there's a cold envelope
you know is he gonna be in that Knicks
jersey Sion Mike I was at that lottery I
know you were loitering I covered that
draft and I just remember everybody was
like he's got to go to the Knicks he's
got to go to the Knicks and all of a
sudden
Patrick Ewing goes to the Knicks and
then and I've been around the
Commissioner Commissioner Stern do not
go there with the commissioner envelope
you know it feels a little cold him and
he'll give you the cold shoulder there
was something like that what do you what
do you want to see him
Durant know I'd like to see him in New
York
not that that owner deserves he
absolutely does not deserve but it I
just want to see the garden come back
because I know what it was and there's a
whole there's like two generations that
don't even know what it was like yeah
and and if you had the the seismic shift
of the NBA would be New York Philly in
Boston again and you would still have
Golden State and maybe the Lakers a
little bit but you'd almost be coming
back you know to the to the 70s and 80s
where you had these teams that were in
contention and and if I could get Zion
in New York because I would tune in to
watch sion play yeah we're gonna we're
gonna watch him almost just almost no
matter where he goes
I just thought by the way about the
Lakers away with the combination suppose
they were to get to bias Harris and klay
Thompson okay so there's no blockbuster
the news is less than blockbuster right
yeah but suppose they put those guys in
the lineup and they they speak the end
they could still trade a couple of
pieces because they'd have still four
guys who train every day they have the
crazy flexibility still you know I don't
think you have to go and have Anthony
Davis if you're the Lakers to get back
in I mean serious contention given what
we've seen LeBrons you know only be
older but he ever do York if you have if
you have the garden that but I was I was
there I loved it my team always took the
Knicks out more times times Michael joy
and by the way don't think when people
ask Jordan about his career life
highlights and they mention different
dunks or just championship or you know
Utah the last shot so the people don't
seem to understand and I haven't even
asked you this lately but one of the
great highlights is not the best given
his feel is love of the garden playing
they're just taking out the Knicks four
times I think with three different
coaches he took Van Gundy out he took
Riley out I don't know and he remembers
every single one of them hey tell Tony
we said hello good to catch up with you
again Mike we appreciate your time as
always buddy no man I appreciate you I
have Michael Wilbon pardon the
interruption if you missed any of our
celebrity interviews this week from the
mercedes-amg man cave go to the Dan
Patrick show app you can watch and
listen from inside the mercedes-amg man
cave mercedes-amg driving performance
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]